bienvenue au premier sumit Open Compute
européen le projet Open Compute est un
projet qui est collaboratif qui a été
lancé en 2011 par facebook avec pour
objectif d'améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique des grands centres de
données informatiques qui stock
aujourd'hui
vos données personnelles et qui qui
doivent les garder dans des endroits
sécurisés d'une manière
efficace l'événement a été coorganisé
avec la Fondation Open Compute aux
États-Unis puis par notre société suite
deskop systems qui est présente sur le
plateau de SACL depuis le mois de
novembre 2006 qui développe des
ordinateurs sur sur ce plateau et je
suis moi-même un ancien étudiant du
plateau de sa donc il nous a semblé
naturel d'essayer d'ancrer cette
communauté autour du futur campus de
l'université Paris
sa on a accueilli plus de 700 personnes
durant cet événement il fallait qu'on
puisse tous se réunir dans une salle
pour pouvoir échanger et donc l'École
polytechnique était la seule école à
disposer de ces moyens logistiqu pour
pouvoir accueillir ce type
d'événement traditionnellement le projet
Open Compute est un projet orienté vers
l'international c'est un projet
communautaire qui traite d'une
problématique assez spécifique du
développement d'équipement matériel donc
traditionnellement en France on est
plutôt orienté logiciel el que
développement matériel la zone US et la
zone Asie sont sont plus dynamiques
autour de autour de cette thématique la
France aujourd'hui est fortement
consommatrice de ces technologies elle
les développe très peu et l'idée c'est
d'essayer justement bah de d'améliorer
ce ce point et de de faire émerger soit
des nouvelles start-ups soit de
sensibiliser une partie de l'écosystème
informatique autour de autour de cette
thématique et de pouvoir développer des
nouvelles technologies et apporter
nous-même notre pierre à
l'édifice la communauté Open Compute est
totalement ouverte donc elle est ouverte
aux étudiants aux retraités aux
professionnels à toutes personne qui
souhaitent s'investir dans cette
communauté et donc naturellement on a
retrouvé un public d'étudiants puis
qu'on est sur un campus universitaire
mais aussi un public de professionnels
avec du networking de haut
niveau